dans cette salle de classe on assiste à
un cours pas comme les autres ici ces
jeunes ne sont plus de simples élèves de
troisième il se transforme en dirigeant
d'entreprise leur société body des monts
vendée beauty de tailles différentes
il ya trois mois six mois et neuf mois
personnalisez donc avec des phrases
fonctionne sans pile par exemple en tout
quinze élèves du collège descartes de
fontenay le fleury volontaire est
sélectionné en début d'année sur lettre
de motivation cette mini entreprise et
encadrés par deux professeurs et un par
un le directeur d'un supermarché
une fois qu'ils sont partis sur leurs
idées body et cetera là en fait on leur
a fait passer des entretiens d'embauché
avec monsieur canaux signé notre parrain
est donc là c'est monsieur canaux
cynique a décidé en fonction des
compétences de chacun et en fonction du
poste pour lequel il avait postulé qui
ferait quoi devant cet ordinateur on
s'occupe de la comptabilité 70
investisseurs ont permis à cette
entreprise de se financer via des
avances remboursables vendus 4 euros une
partie d'entre eux sera présente à
l'assemblée générale de l'entreprise au
clavier on s'active car tout doit être
au point pour cette réunion les statuts
de l'entreprise notamment à droite
ce groupe est chargé du design des body
aujourd'hui il finalise le logo dernière
étape avant la fabrication et le comble
pas mal du tout mais il faut aussi
penser à la vente
les jeunes tiendront un stand eux le 29
mai dans le supermarché de leurs
parrains et marie et ses collègues ont
une idée pour booster leurs ventes là en
fait on a préparé un dialogue que j'ai
fait un téléphone tout à l'heure pour
appeler un clown
dieu des médecins le rire des médecins
pardon et donc on va leur demander de
venir à notre stand
direction le bureau de la principale
pour téléphoner à cette association body
b compte de leur reverser 15 % de leurs
ventes
première démarche commerciale pour marie
alors elle est un peu stressé gauche qui
avec les médicaments les opérations cela
semble bien parti pour au body b
cette entreprise n'est pas la seule du
genre l'association agir pour
entreprendre inciter les établissements
scolaires à se lancer dans l'aventuré
cette année dans les yvelines 12 mini
entreprises ont vu le jour